[Music]
so
do any of you guys what are you guys
looking at i don't know he was like
looking here so i was just like
you just got in trouble by the teacher
would you like to share with the class
uh i think the secret was uh i said it
was a secret
yeah yeah i'm gonna call your parents
nelson ryan marchart march down to the
principal's office
the t.a the enforcer
is pat gonna scold me in there he's the
principal
i'm a mascot
peanuts characters yeah
okay so there is this tick tock trend
that's
pretty dangerous for your teeth have you
guys come across it oh what is it
i don't know it has a million trends is
it the does it have to pop rocks
okay teeth no any other guesses
oh does it involve flying to turkey
[Laughter]
is it like mentos and coke inside no
nothing
no is it corn on the cob um
is it don't visit the dentist for a long
time oh i'm
really good at doing that me too
professional all right so the trend it
seems or i don't know if i should call
it a trend
or maybe i don't is to do this
can you make it out what is that a file
on your teeth
their teeth with a nail file no
to even out there but the ridges are
gone
not just that they could be doing some
serious
permanent damage to their teeth the
enamel
what the heck yeah how viral can you go
well i don't know if they were trying to
do it for
viral's sake but it seems like they're
doing it for cosmetic
purposes and it's not a good idea
according to dentists who are who are
like debunking this
according to tick-tock dentists there
are tick-tock dentists no they are i'm
gonna show you something yeah
you met one i did a playlist oh really
yeah
he's a nice fella he has lime uh shoes
it's like part of his brand
oh only shoes that's the only thing he's
wearing he's like
they're crocs or something but yeah he's
a nice fella
cool i say fella hello
yeah okay so here there are
uh some tick tocks i'm about to show you
and you can see for yourself the the
dentists are going to be giving you guys
some advice oh okay okay okay thank god
i don't want to see them filing their
teeth
oh you did see it oh she did it did it
as a dentist when my patient asked me to
do this the first thing that i think
about is why are their teeth uneven in
the first place in this case it's
because the lower teeth are crowded
and are unevenly wearing the upper teeth
okay you file them and they look pretty
good
but you didn't solve the original
problem so what are you gonna do in a
few years when they're uneven again
and now your teeth are shorter i'm about
to do something really down so i'm going
to take you on the gym the second one
of filing my teeth this journey now
attack trend all right okay
should you file down your teeth with a
nail file here's what we have to
remember
is our teeth are made up of layers if
you destroy your enamel by filing down
your teeth you will never get it back
you may end up with extreme tooth
sensitivity or even cause enough damage
to kill the tooth
a dead tooth needs extensive and
expensive treatment if you want to keep
it
don't consider doing this seriously
don't do it
i'm not i'm now okay with banning tic
tocs yeah it's like all right well maybe
it's not the worst i think it's sensible
we're not losing much there being banned
god
it's just every time did they got it
close i was just like because my teeth
are sensitive already
so i'm just like oh ah dude my teeth are
sensitive because i did this to myself
without wanting to do it to myself are
you grinding like grinding my teeth ever
since high school like i i'm telling you
guys i would wake up in the morning and
have like little
chunks of my teeth in my mouth because
i'd be like grinding so [ __ ] hear it
at night sometimes like when i'm like
tossing and turning and i'm like
i wake up for a split second and then
you'll be me tossing and turning makes
you toss and turn which then makes you
grind your teeth like oh
do you have a do you have a mouth guard
now or well now i wear invisalign
so that's kind of that's basically a
mouth guard in the meantime but then
once i'm done with the treatment then i
have to wear a night guard makeup they
make a nice one because my girlfriend
has a
grinding teeth problem like it'll be so
loud that i'll have to wake her up
because it's like
hey it's like she's like forward okay
and then she goes back to again
immediately
um but they make more comfortable ones
now instead of having the wearing the
entire mouth guard around all of your
teeth yeah
it just covers your back like oh tight
so it's much more comfortable
oh yeah yeah cause she tried the whole
thing and she couldn't sleep with it so
she link me because yeah
um man nikki has that too for sure give
me the link for that too because yeah
nelson
does that well not this nelson but my
man yeah
does that too and i wake up and i hear
him like grind his teeth and so what i
usually do is i like
flap his face a little bit like hey oh
[ __ ] because because like even
no how hard no it's very gentle it's
like this okay julia gentle
is oh
yeah no like i would have to like kind
of like do this because hey stop
because like if i try to like move his
body or anything like he won't really
respond so i have to like be like this
like
stop doing that no man because of me
grinding my teeth
at night like i had like jaw problems
like i actually realized oh my god you
guys want to see it's [ __ ] crazy yeah
so i realized my jaw is placed
wrong or something i have to go to my
dentist and get this professionally
analyzed but the reason why i found out
is because look
if i open my mouth like just open it
looks fine right like this
okay okay right okay kind of yeah okay a
little it looked all right look a little
crooked
the one that's really [ __ ] up is when
i try to bring my jaw out
look i'm confused what are we looking
for i think i'm seeing regular [ __ ] am i
crazy do you see how good it is going to
the
left you're gonna know is it oh yeah
oh yeah this thing oh yeah oh yeah
oh okay okay that's
it mine normal it's straight wait do the
do the open mouth one to me this angle
it looks it looks normal that looks
normal but oh [ __ ]
i don't know you do it no what we look
stupid you do it yeah i don't
look guys it's stupid look i'm not
scared of looking stupid you guys
already know me but look
it's just crooked as [ __ ]
dude i was cracking up with him too
because i was taking pictures i'm like
look at this photo look you have a
warning before you do that
you're probably eating food or something
you're like in their home like
[Laughter]
you're welcome i'm so sorry everybody
this is like a vr episode you're just
like looking around the room i'll say
tuesday
oh night but dude for real like my
shit's [ __ ] up
like it hurts up here i think i need to
get it alive does your jaw click
sometimes yeah i have a t it's like what
cmg
j j yeah tmj yeah so there's a part
where like my jaw would dislocate when i
open my
mouth at the bottom position it goes
yeah and it goes it just kind of kicks
out and but now i've like grinded it
down like my jaw is ground down to where
it doesn't it just it grinds like you
can
my sister has that yeah it doesn't pop
anymore is that the name of it
tmj yeah yeah my sister can't suck dick
cause of that it's terrible
[Laughter]
wow what a loss it's too bad yeah kind
of uncomfortable you know that though
yeah i know a lot of all my sister
messages are very attractive woman
double and down oh older sister younger
sister i didn't know you guys older but
she looks younger outside of that
[Laughter]
i didn't fall for it
i'm surprised by instinctually like you
usually do
that's true i'm the kind of guy if you
raise your hand always might enter for
some reason i'm like i don't know
but that was just so yeah i'm just so
just like
so on edge that's so funny man
i know the other day i was asking him to
grab me something and next to oh i was
asking him to get a remote and right
next to the remote was a tape dispenser
but then like we were in mid
conversation and he just grabs the tapes
and spencer gives to me and i'm like
we're trying to watch a movie
what i need to say i don't know
it's so funny but yeah anyway grinding
your teeth down don't do it people
don't believe everything you see on tick
tock what are the benefits of this
to them the straightness straight yeah
even for like [ __ ]
couple days
it hurts i think about it and i just
like hurt i can't
i can't i need to go to a dentist saying
i've been like i uh
i i luckily luckily and unluckily i
guess i got my health insurance like
late later into the year so then it was
after rona started
um so i said okay at least i need health
insurance right and then it was like oh
do you want to add dental i was like i'm
not going in that office anytime soon
no thank you smart guy i'm waiting until
next year to get dental again
i got dental what's the [ __ ] point
exactly
thank you really never go well no i i
was planning on going but then norma
happened so i'm not gonna go for a
minute
really because i mean you could still go
yeah the offices are open now
i actually i've been to the dentist like
five times
in the past there's a reason why we
didn't drive or we didn't fly to vegas
we drove to vegas because like you know
we just want to be careful because i
want to be able to see my
my mom and dad and nikki's parents no
but if you were gonna go
anywhere like dentists i feel like is
really safe because how safe do you feel
when you go into a dentist office or an
office of any sort and then they they
do the temperature thing for to your
forehead yeah they don't touch my phone
and then and they
find they ask you questions like have
you had a feeling they also make you
like sanitize your hands they like i
know it's great it's not about that
though yeah i don't think i'm
worried that i'm just gonna get sick
there like either i think it's just like
i don't know
it just feels like going into an office
of any kind like
where there's a bunch of people and i'm
just i don't know it just feels weird
well there's not a bunch of people
because they're actually doing things
where you have to
make a schedule you there is no more
waiting rooms you have to wait in your
car
so there aren't a bunch of people you
walk in when or you call them when you
arrive and then they tell you when to
walk in what i'm saying is i don't like
going to the dentist
that's exactly what i think i'm afraid
yeah let me be honest
i'm like give me more reasons i'll be
[ __ ] you wanted to pull it out to be
there
fine i'm a little guy with a little dick
don't be afraid to be honest guys after
after hearing your wisdom teeth pulling
story i would not
have so many cravings i don't want to go
back to the to that particular what
happened
so many bad stories like like just
stories of like
going to the dentist they put in like
the the number okay yeah
and then they come back and they're like
hey is it numb yet and i said no and
they're like
too bad and then they're like don't be
just a wuss and then it's like hurry no
time they're like
he's just a wuss he's like they're like
telling my parents uh and then in the
car at home it starts becoming numb and
i'm like wow wow
i wish this happened earlier oh no stuff
like that it's fun
damn no sorry you're probably allergic
or something
or like something's going on with you i
think his doctors are just bad
yeah i just didn't they didn't wait
because you're supposed to wake up this
wisdom teeth pulling story like
that too yeah then like i i i went to
the dentist
uh last year or no no actually no
earlier this year
because i had to get my wisdom teeth
pulled out which i was so upset
because in because wisdom teeth are
supposed to come typically when you're
in high school or like in college right
so i got to the dentist during those
times and they said like yeah i don't
see any wisdom teeth
you're pretty much good to go and i was
like cool and he was like yeah you were
missing four teeth when you were a kid
and i guess you're now like you don't
have wisdom teeth so you're probably
involved human i'm like
dope that's awesome i called you an
evolved human yeah right
and then so then i go back to the
dentist to get like a teeth cleaning and
whatnot and they're like huh
we kind of see some wisdom teeth growing
it and i was like excuse me no you're
talking to an evolved human
excuse me no way on the ball impossible
and then my death was like yeah i i see
i see
i see some here and i was like you you
told me oh it's the same dentist it was
the same dances i was like you told me
that i wasn't gonna have wisdom teeth
and he was like
you're a late bloomer and i was like no
i don't want to believe that then he was
like well we should set an appointment
to like get your teeth pulled out like
[ __ ] that well i might just say [ __ ]
that's him but like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you buddy that's right pal
i'm getting a second opinion on these
wisdom dudes
yeah and then like i was just freaking
out about it because like i don't know i
just feel like definitely as i've grown
older like i'm just
more fearful of pain or being in pain
and it's just like the idea of
one i hate the dentist a lot and then
two is just like
putting myself into that position of
like losing something
which would probably benefit me in the
long run was just like something that
was like scary because i haven't put
myself in that position in like a long
time i guess
and so um when i was like asking
everybody like the crew of like
what was your wisdom teeth experience
like and then some people were like oh
yeah i was knocked out
and then they also like nope i just got
numbing shots and i was like what
yeah i just got numbing shots and then
it just went worse from there
and then basically like he like it was
it was dramatic because it was like uh
like here right turn this way oh nice
wait okay yeah
we have an example just lean back okay
and then what like
is this in camera what kind of dent
all his way into my jaw and i was like
oh god there's so much
oh my god can i ask can i was it a
vietnamese doctor
absolutely whoa that's all i needed [ __ ]
and i was like [ __ ] scared because
i had to go to him
i know there are decent dentists and
stuff like that but it was just like i
don't know i feel like
my relationship with the dentist hasn't
been so great because i used to have
braces and stuff you know they have to
change out the bands right
and so they use like that hook to get
those bands out
every single time on that chair like i'm
always gripping the armrest because i'm
just afraid that they're gonna [ __ ]
jab me in the lip right
so the one day i was like you know what
i've gone here for like half a year
i should be good now like they're
professionals they've done this like
i've witnessed that they haven't
jabbed me in the lip the moment i
thought that the lady jabbed me in the
[ __ ] lip and i was like
[ __ ] the dentist i don't [ __ ] care
anymore i don't trust them with my mouth
the law of attraction julia you brought
it on to yourself
but i went to a different fault i went
to a different dentist and got my wisdom
teeth pulled out
and then it just ended up being the top
two but so it wasn't too bad
but the only person i chose was my mouth
is my sister
this is the worst
[Music]
you